but uh you're gonna be happy Connor why
finally watched John Wick 4. oh you did
yeah America yeah in America oh [__]
unfortunately I didn't watch John Wick
3. what the [__]
what the [__] is wrong with you you you
Rose it up back down I will say I don't
really think it matters because that
implies that the plot in John Wick
actually matters which yeah okay
it doesn't [__] matter oh my yes it
does the plot is fine you don't even
know the why why what the [__] it's okay
because uh dietus was like we're
watching John Wick 4 now and uh you know
I was like I haven't just seen John with
three and he's like I don't care I'll
just explain everything to you and he
explained it all in like
stylus doesn't even know what happened
that is terrible
um yeah I don't know you probably don't
even know oh my God like there's so many
like the starting scenes are all like
the the the
[__] backstory to what happened in
the previous movie The reason why oh my
God I mean okay listen you can still
enjoy the movie but like you're missing
out on some pretty good story it's not
the best but it's great man you know the
whole friendship between oh [__] my God
man you just ruined
I've never seen Connor this Lost Boy
you could have watched a 10 minute
summary on YouTube before you went in I
had I had diets with me
he is I loved iters to death but that
man cannot explain like a 10 second
summary this man cannot explain no
because every time something relevant to
like the previous films happened he
would be like he would literally like
pause and be like okay so this happened
this happened he didn't watch it in the
cinemas uh no we uh [__] we watched it
on like uh home Cinema stream yeah uh
yeah he would just pause there and just
explained everything that happened and
everything he was explaining I was like
uh that's really useful information that
I don't give a [__] about I just want to
see uh people shoot the [__] out of each
other
um
I think John Wick 4 had the best action
I you know I've seen in the [__] long
time the action scenes were absolutely
[__] stunning but I'm gonna kill you
I did not think it needed to be three
hours long I I fell I felt fatigue after
the first because you weren't invested
in the story
okay okay here's my biggest here's my
biggest gripe okay here's my here's my
here's my biggest gripe okay if we
wanted it to be longer okay if we're
gonna okay if we're gonna like talk
about the story right
there are some things where I just like
could not wrap my head around okay uh
don Yen's character all right donnian's
character uh so I didn't know coming
into this that he's a blind he's a blind
guy right you mean you [__] see he's
blind he's not in any of the movies no
no I mean I I didn't know coming into
this movie that he was going to be a
blind character
um whoa so I I so I thought that he was
going to be some like [__] Daredevil
kind of character who could like sense
everything based on like his sense of
like sound or something and then like
the first scene it becomes very obvious
that oh no he's actually blind and it
doesn't help him at all right why would
it help him think of being blind gives
you superpowers she was Marvel he's seen
so much anime
he's like no he's gonna pull out the one
piece hockey anytime soon bro so what
what I couldn't get my head around was
okay are you blind and goaded or are you
blind oh yeah
and the there are so many scenes that
flip-flop between the both because he's
still [__] done again he's kicking
ass and then there'll be points where
he's just like uh are you dead I uh I
can't tell I I can't tell and I'm like
how is this guy still alive I don't I
don't get it how how is this assassin
still alive it's like it's like scenes
as well where he's trying to find the
gun and he can't find you yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's get there like that's like
you know I don't need I don't want to be
dead so what you're saying is he's a
little bit too inconsistent yeah yeah I
just like I was I I like the I like to
disabled enough
I just wish he was more blind no no no
all I'm talking about is uh with
suspension of disbelief I I love batshit
crazy things right yeah but it needs to
make sense within the logic of its own
world if something doesn't make sense
with it within the logic of its own
world I just it just like there's it's
just like a pin pin prick in my brain
where I just like I can't ignore it and
just like I was going into every scene
being like so he's is he a blind man or
is he like a Jedi it's not I was like
sometimes he's a blind man sometimes
he's a [__] Jedi Master [__] feels
the fish does all that [__] and I'm like
is he blind or is he just yeah it was
pretty consistent I thought it was all
right and uh yeah there and and I like
the campiness the cheesiness of John
Wick this there are there are some
points that when that were just like a
little bit too far for me at at some
points in this where I was just like
okay this is uh which part such as for
example um well don't spoil too much
because I started seeing okay okay
[Music]
like I mean
it doesn't have that much of a plot
let's be honest uh the the the main the
main the main villain of John Wick was
the most cartoonish kind of like villain
yeah it was great
he was he was like he was like way too
[__] cartoonish he was just like
let's just make that you you just like
that because he's just like a seeing a
Frenchman getting [__]
that's the British in you man
it makes sense I mean so this whole
world is kind of like cartoon was he
like a bond villain or something he was
like a bond villain sometimes like a
hundred he was like he wasn't that bad I
mean it's it's like he's like evil for
evil sake but it makes sense does he
have an evil mustache no he doesn't oh
although I wouldn't be enough censored
in the world though in the the rules you
know yeah that he broke the rules I I
think I think that I think that was the
thing that bothered me about John Wick 4
because as you find out more about the
rules of this assassin world because in
like John Wick one and two it was kind
of like a surface kind of thing where
it's like oh this cool thing exists uh
these are what the rules of the Assassin
worlds are
um and you're like okay that's enough of
a background thing where I can just
focus on the action but what I found
with John Wick 4 was that it was so like
it was way more ingrained to the plot
line and then I had that like third
movie to kind of transition you into it
probably
no I I still I still don't think I've
missed much you did you did I'm going to
watch the third movie and I'm gonna be
like I'm gonna be like okay so uh he
hates this one that guy betrayed that
person so much in the third movie and he
got another dog
that's so much sick no but like what
what bothered me was there were just
like little inconsistencies I found
within the logic of its own world uh
where just some some like I'm I'm all
for suspension of disbelief but there
are just some things where it just took
things a bit too far when there was more
focus on it uh that just I couldn't
ignore it as much I don't know how
you're going so in depth into this like
probably more than any reviewer and
retaliation is not
betrayed that person that person is
friends with that person okay I
understand yeah the John Wick shoot the
fourth has like the least plot
like because he has like barely any
lines in it he barely says anything he's
like 200 words in the whole movie I mean
that was also consistent with like the
three other movies
no no the third is very plot heavy I
can't believe it I've only seen the
first one so I don't know I guess I've
seen now I've seen like three out of the
four John Wick movies and I couldn't
remember I can remember like two lies
that he's ever you're like Jojo Parts
but John Wicked it was not happy
this skipped part three that's like
skipping the second Lord of the Rings
film being like no okay we're not We're
Not Gonna compare to Lord of the [__]
Rings okay this is this is what I'm
saying is yeah you could obviously gloss
over [__] but you're still missing
important plot points look I don't watch
John Wick for the plot I watch it before
they watch John Wick for the plot [__]
the action is a side bonus question shut
the [__] up
that's so cute I don't want [__] for the
like amazing Oscar Oscar nominated
writing of John Wick Whose Line includes
yeah and I love it yeah
when he says yeah I get chopped I mean I
mean likewise but it's not a plot Point
yeah it's like it's kind of uh yeah yeah
okay actually actually uh okay the one
the one scene that bothered me the ones
okay one scene that bothered me
the [__] uh there's a scene with a
literal [__] James Bond villain where
they play poker together and this is
really it's it's this really badass
scene where they play poker together and
the stakes are meant to be high the
poker game means [__] nothing because
they're like okay so the winner of the
the like the loser of the poker game has
to do X or has to do I can't actually
remember the stakes yeah of the poker
game but I remember being high stakes
and then and then they go through this
like 20 minute long scene it's not a 20
minute [__] off it's like five minutes
gone like they go through this long
scene Universal poker scene and then
they just start shooting each other
anyway so I'm like okay
like you could have just shot the bad
guy immediately and just foregone this
song they have to create like suspense
right they have to be like oh okay is he
actually gonna like play by the rules
this time or is he gonna be John Wick
and just start guns are blazing turns
out he's John Wick why am I defending
this movie
civilized political discussions in John
Wick like you know that was gonna happen
no no I'm like why are you I feel like
you're comparing this scene to like like
a build up I can't just have him run up
in a place you'd be like all right
people I I I mean I the thing that
bothered me was just like why are we
pretending why are we pretending to have
a plot here why are we pretending that
this means anything
like I said John Wick that's exciting
like did they really need poker and
Casino Royale like did they come on they
didn't matter in the end like you need
that that's like what the [__]
I was like we should remove all dialogue
from films I feel as I feel maybe they
added that scene because after four
movies and you know many many different
scenes and situations
shooting [__] they're probably just like
all right we gotta change it up uh we've
done a building we've done a house we've
done the streets we've done the club
we've done every other place where have
we not shot guns at yet poker game and
they just throw that in I I guarantee
that's how it was chosen I love that
fight scene though the fight scene was
[__] insane all the fight scenes all
the fight scenes were so good oh my God
I'm just yeah the thing that bothered me
wasn't the fight scenes it was just like
I said
um you know I could turn my brain off
for the first and second one the fourth
one because there were so many more
moving Parts in the first and second one
it was just like just noticed too many
like internal inconsistencies with its
own logic in this world and that just
kind of like took me out I disagree I
feel I feel John Wick is just like the
live-action God of high school no no
where it's just like the fight scenes
are epic but what the [__] is this plot
disagree yes
John Wick has a better plot yeah way
better go to high school literally
doesn't have a plot it sounds like John
Wick no don't I'm so fat I can't believe
you just skip this probably you have
proposed the idea of John Wick 4 and
you're like Avengers actually no I I
didn't purposely skip John Wick three uh
didus just like refused to let me not
watch it he was like we're [__] job
we're [__] watching John Wick fall
together and you're sitting down I'm
like I haven't seen the third one and
he's like I don't care you are you
realize he just wanted to watch it he
wanted to do that yeah so blame dieters
yeah I'll take it I'll take it